[Music]
the full scope of a nuclear that girl
is almost
unemotional polynomials will ever
experienced another vision gareth
chart incidence of this
scientifically supported by en or action
the keys 100 or 1000 of lines in the
area surrounding and u color explosion
so what is display  and what ik business
would it protects from the creator
destructive blessed days' weapons harness
the power of nuclear fusion in which en
adam's nucleus is split into this
process producers and incredible amount
of energy and in some materials
de nu btw produced by one vision of
george  a new my arms
splitting additional nuclear the chain
reaction scamper so al ranger explosion
kept the leds consider en explosion
i want a tip 10.000 our tnt en
explosion like this would create a final
kill a fascinating of use
citybox en er shockwave damaging building
several hours a  week
there is criticism lee nothing with capital
and so a box in the fireballs radius
ever for those in sho  ck wave and pia land
a scientific lisabo this protocol
could be lifesaving and do the most commendable
the best know stay protected before
during and after nu color damnation
is caring in sign similar to protecting
your self from tornado's over games
getting and stone in side  story building
bhutan for protection of die explosion
shockwave
and radiation de shockwave of energy
travel saville glamorous beyond
fireballs relief in the first few seconds
study building's met in nairobi able to
which they en de shockwave
and stone in de centrum en b's people
peace building of zo  money trail eye
protection
van vliet in final jacks
finding shelter is a special import and
i the fireball
gary's close studios and single core
1000 thrones actor and de brie
savelkoul amateurs interior s the
firewall cool
unstable arms created by the nucleation
nothing to do with the de brie who passed out  10
dress long time effect of a new word
and nation radioactive particles gold
follow the same  size particles in met
arjen icing radiation
capable of set redirect runs of
molecules and the adam's exposure to
blades of people this relation
can result in cell damage radiation burns
radiation sickness
catcher anyone that created several
commerce at
dangers concentrations of this material
will be given by upper  atmospheric mens
potential leading to measure this level
they fall into aliens ad columns
restaurant
thankfully the theme building' surfer
protection of the
blest even better at kardinge chance of
falling
radiation is reduced and travels to
space and mass
both pants in window and sealed
window  so have a minimal effect on
radiation
fiddlers silent concrete and pack
words can offer sirius protection and
since paul gins
gave off wind energy in the first hour nad
percent in first they stay inside
family for our future makkelie
series is effective radiation following
the blows there would be  released 15
minutes to find shelter voor de val of
begins since de most hazard is
follow-up articles of de hbs
they think to the air and collect on
street en rooftops metering ideal shelters
underground hoor in a resource of
high-rise buildings but if someone  who i
get caught in the fall out there still
measures decotape after finding a save
space
offers ridgid medical attention
tricycle outside help after and power by
part i stay inside and stay tuned for
more information for first responders
where electric power cells service
internet agency that language had to
survive regions with like me
soloists informagency responders
vitamin c peace corps rail
nuclear weapons of some  of the most
powerful tools of destruction on earth
and this my seminar on the boat vvd
straightforward protective  measures wat
stories and simulations have repeatedly
shown the benefits of chain in site
both will hopefully i never need to
remember to
greensight stay inside and stay tuned when
and nuclear war
domains die tess had them way wrong
in this episode cuban missile crisis
yo in which  helps careful the police and
onemen scrooge
preventive and international catastrophe
[Music]